from Los Angeles California it's the
2015 view reviewers movie awards the
only award show exclusively presented by
the YouTube movie your community hosted
by Jeremy Jones and from OHS no Marc
Ellis
hello friends fans fanatics of movies
like myself and these guys you know me
I'm Jeremy Jones we're in the schmoes no
studio with this rose I'm Christian hey
and I'm mark welcome to year five of the
you reviewers Awards I can't believe
it's five years too late we've done this
for five years it started out with a
simple idea just the fact I think that I
called you up one day yeah after um it
was a simple snob really was a snub it
was Kristin Christopher Nolan didn't get
anything or any recognition by the
Oscars for inception stuff yeah and well
you know what nothing against the Oscars
but II don't I don't think that that
Academy really is watching movies the
way that the fans ooh the way we do so
right put something together and we did
in the year of yours was born yeah he
calls me up he's like I mean like you
said you know there's no connection
between the award shows and the fans and
he was like why don't we give that to
them I was like yeah person I I don't
know it all let's do that really do it
for five years well we'd be doing it for
half a decade probably not but it'll be
fun I love that idea I was in the
bathroom when they were talking out the
details and I get to wear a suit once a
year so party on he still doesn't know
that he's here no idea
no and it's really cool because we get
people all over and it's it's just
evolved every year and we have a lot of
great presenters here people that you
know whether it be Andre from black nerd
comedy pretty much it Chris Stockman AMC
movie talk there's so many people now
involved it's a lot of fun to watch it
grow yeah for sure
and I mean it's kind of a collaboration
a digital collaboration through those
those Internet's between us and the fans
and I love the categories too because
some of these you're gonna see at the
big award shows like the Oscars or the
Golden Globes that we have some that are
very specific to the year's awards and
it's beautiful that the Best Picture now
the fans vote right no pressure guys but
this is actually on you and if it sucks
it's your fault Godzilla come on and
kicking off this award show we're going
to go to the biceps of YouTube giving us
the winner
the category Best Supporting Actor flick
pick you take it away man either guys my
name is John I come from the flick pick
channel very magical mystical land far
beyond the mountaintops really hobbits
and robots live it's getting weird
so anyway there's my channel right there
epic elbow drop now let's talk about the
nominees for best supporting actor of
2014 and the nominees are Edward Norton
Birdman Mark Ruffalo Foxcatcher
Ethan Hawke boyhood JK Simmons whiplash
Toby Kebbell dawn of the Planet of the
Apes we have a squeaker today class his
name's Andrew Neiman he's 19 years old
isn't he cute and the winner is JK
Simmons from whiplash that would have
been my pick to soda way guys it was fun
to be back here on year five of you
reviewers back to you JK Simmons as king
dick of the universe and whiplash I love
it I mean that's the one I think he's a
lock in every other eye oh absolutely
just knew from the second he was
nominated when the videos went off with
like we know JK Simmons is probably
gonna win anyone by Al and another one
tell everybody watching the show there's
gonna be a lot more suspense than we
just went through but now we're getting
warm now we're getting less congrats to
JK Simmons by far the best performance I
saw from a supporting actor this year
yeah flip it kills it as usual it's
really energetic a lot of fun I'd loved
watching that guy yeah and like we said
before since JK Simmons is a lock for
everything oscars if you get it wrong it
is your fault and our next category is
most underrated film that movie that
maybe you heard about it maybe you
didn't see it but maybe you should have
presenting is our friends pretty much it
guys who won who was the most underrated
howdy Sh'ma Vil hi guys mmm we're
actually in our parents basement because
our studio we're in between studios are
so sorry for that horrifying intro but
guess what even though people perished
in the fire 2015 thank you so much of
the schmoes and Jeremy Jones for having
us always great to be here these guys
are great we have to tell you what the
most underrated film is unique I've
overrated you know underrated first of
all we have the nominees which were lock
edge of tomorrow
snowpiercer begin again and the guests
did you see any of those oh you know why
cuz they were underrated yeah Mike there
can only be one winner and that winner
is of course its edge of tomorrow
obviously
yeah the guest was really guest was
great too so these are all good picks
for a most underrated film this is great
because number one Tom Cruise is number
two on my list of people I would want to
be my dad number one he's number two on
my list yeah number two yeah also all
damn practical effects yes yeah we
always get that always comes up on the
show like how like awesome that is
congratulations Tom Cruise I think he's
gonna be accepting this personally yeah
thank you again to the schmoes and
Jeremy Jones back to you edge of
tomorrow all you need is kill so many
different titles and yet it still wins
and I'll tell you I it was I didn't know
who's gonna be doing that and the guest
because a lot of people were talking
about the guest yeah enough more people
had to see it and it was a pretty close
race I was looking I was looking at some
of these tallies it was a pretty close
race but you look into those Tom Cruise
eyes is it a race really is it a race I
don't know that movie to me do you think
that because it eventually when it came
out in the theater was pretty underrated
new style off it was Tina but then it
caught so much buzz later I think now
it's properly rated but again these are
films that came out this year and from
what it had
battle against because everybody saw the
trailer frigid tomorrow I was like oh
this is gonna be another oblivion it
looks boring and it was anything but
that I love this movie so much I did a
Tough Mudder in Seattle in honor of the
blu-ray release of edge of tomorrow
somehow I survived in my hometown thanks
for calling me mark I didn't know who do
you think you deserve
edge' tomorrow yeah oh yeah I mean that
was on my top ten that's a lot of fun
and that's the important thing about
movies that movies have to be fun movies
like that there are movies that have to
be deeper they have to have a deeper
meaning some movies let's just kick back
and have something really cool and it
had all of that but it did have those
moments of you know heart and and
meaning you know so I mean I think edge
of tomorrow yeah I thought it was gonna
win it also had a Emily Blunt it had
Emily Blunt who could kick my ass you
see her biceps tonight movie pay to
watch that oh my god alright and thank
you to pretty much it again for
presenting the award Jeremy what's up
next yeah
love you guys alright our next category
is best hero the ones you can look up to
the ones the ones on your kids TV tray
best heroine to present we got Erin
Robinson from clever movies Erin who won
what's up internet friends I'm Erin
Robinson and you probably know me from
over on clever movies and if you haven't
heard of us
then you should totally check us out in
all the usual places on YouTube on
Facebook on Twitter at clever movies you
guys I love movies I love talking about
movies so let's just say I'm pretty
daggone stoked that I was chosen to
present the category of best freaking
hero its best hero but I threw the
freaking in because it's so awesome
alright and the nominees are
what'a rama from the raid - Captain
America from Captain America the Winter
Soldier right
these are from dawn of the Planet of the
Apes
strong
star-lord from guardians of the galaxy
who star-lord man legendary outlaw guys
forget it and last but certainly not
least it's John wick from John wick that
dog was a final gift from my dying wife
it's personal
all right this is a really hard one but
you guys chose a winner and it is things
are gonna get easier galaxy cutie
awesome mix I'm gonna get my groove
dancing on but you guys don't forget to
check us out on clever movies or you can
check me out on Twitter at hater and
Robin sent back to you fellas
star-lord the Seahawks fan of cinema I
love you star-lord that's why I'm glad
you won and you talked about this guy
being everywhere and now he's a winner
on the gyro viewers Awards and it was
that last year I think was Katniss that
one I don't know at the end Katniss was
I mean well that will Eve that launched
her career and now Chris Pratt's gonna
get more well it's you reviewers you
waited you reviewers award you're pretty
much on the money and not just that in
any years this was a stacked year for a
heroes man and the fact that Chris Pratt
comes on top he's being named for every
big franchise that's coming out and he's
got that robot ninja cowboy thing he's
got maybe he's gonna be the next Indiana
Jones but for right now I love this dude
as Star Wars and to be fair star-lord
won the award and star-lord is a guy who
you didn't really know anything about
him you knew nothing about gardens did
galaxy except like the hardcore comic
book fans right star-lord is it you go
to the comic you go to Comic Con you go
to anything at however your people
address them in the jackets so yeah it
makes sense of star-lord wins best hero
because he is now he's it he's a new
hero that everyone sees absolutely he's
a name and what I like about him is that
he's he's the relatable he's the he is
the Indiana Jones of the stars you know
Nathan Drake he's got a little more
Nathan he's going to say he's the next
Nathan Drake talker he's you know he's
cool but he's funny but he's adventurous
and he'll throw down when he needs to
definitely would have handed the ball
off to Marshawn Lynch yeah he that's
what I think he would have handed the
little little trinket they were going
farther than
erecta Marjan what chris pratt him with
you why didn't that happen it
our next category is breakthrough actor
the one he's not quite ryan gosling yet
but he could be Ryan Gosling tomorrow
you didn't know his name you know his
name now to present we got Mike from
belated media Mike who killed it
hey all I'm Michael Barrett II from
belated media and I'm here to present
that you reviewers Award for
breakthrough actor whether you started
on stage television or even at the early
age of six a breakthrough role can mean
the world to you and all of the actors
in 2014 offered strong performances and
then some but only one will be taking
the award and the nominees are Jack
O'Connell for unbroken Dan Stevens for
the guest Ellar Coltrane for boyhood
Ansel Elgort for divergent in The Fault
in Our Stars and Jamie Lieber hurt for
Saint Vincent and whether they win this
award or not all US reviewers are
keeping our eyes on all's y'all cuz like
IMDB is definitely a thing and man you
guys are dealing with some heavy hitting
directors in the upcoming future
Jaden Lee be here working on the next
Cameron Crowe film Jack O'Connell and
Terry Gilliam's the man who shot Don
Quixote I mean I'm just stoked for you
guys but enough beating around the bush
ru reviewers award goes to Dan Stevens
so congratulations Dan and keep loving
movies guys as for me well I gotta get
back to working on episode 3 otherwise
I'll be crucified by the internet Dan
Stevens ladies and gentlemen in a film
that you saw sure Dana film that you saw
did not in a film that I have rented in
my itunes queue so that's something it's
told that you know what that's what I
love about the awards is the fact that
everyone who did see it all the you
reviewers that voted on it it was like
Dan Stevens Dan Stevens I ever heard of
this guy but running through all the
nominations and I want to see the guest
and from what our engineer our lovely
jte says right is that this movie is a
throwback to like not only it's not
really har as much it's like an old
action film and Dan Stevens apparently
knocked it out of the park and you guys
didn't see this but when Dan Stevens was
announced JT actually [ __ ] himself yeah
sure did and the next category is the
you reviewers exclusive category I'm
shocked it didn't suck it's that movie
you see the trailer and you're like
there's no way in hell I'm watching that
movie and then you see the movie and
you're like I'm so glad I watched that
movie to present we have Scott mance and
my future Aussie wife Alicia
from profiles guys take it away hey
there I'm Alicia Malone and I'm Scott
Manson we are the hosts of profiles with
Malone immense and we got all dressed up
to give you the nominees for the
category I'm shocked it didn't suck at
this year's you reviewers Awards take it
away the nominees are the purge and our
key draft day top 5 John wick and edge
of tomorrow and the winner is John wick
I agree with this one because I thought
this movie would suck I thought it would
too but I have to say I would have gone
with edge of tomorrow there's a movie I
really thought would suck and it was
awesome but oh well John wick is the
winner well you can catch us every week
on profiles with Malone and mats on the
popcorn talk network by Keanu with guns
this is this is this is another one race
and it was between John wick and edge of
tomorrow ok is back because a lot of
people because of edge of tomorrow used
like you were saying before with
oblivion everyone thought it is give me
a blini until I go this is gonna be
terrible right when you go in there and
it didn't but I think because people
started talking about it so much like
John wick came out of nowhere right and
tomorrow still had Tom Cruise in it Jeff
wick had canneries and you never know
what you're getting from that dude
performance wise and he ended up being
perfect for this role absolutely it
might be an argument where it's like the
edge of tomorrow surprised us maybe it
fed into John wick probably not but
maybe
and it's counterweight the Keanu Reeves
is one of say what you will about Keanu
Reeves I've said a lot about Keanu
Reeves he's one of the most likable
badasses movies when he has a gun and
he's just kicking ass him like Keanu
Reeves
show us what's up yeah I give him like
the like of a bad actor thing - yeah
he's never he's never he's never so
great but he's so likable you want to
say I guess and he can kick ass yeah the
matrix and he did in this movie and when
I saw this movie I was expecting it to
be like horrible it's not a good movie
in one and you just have so much fun
it's not just him in the film it's this
whole movie just has such a ball telling
the silly 80s action vibe story next
time I go on the road I'm staying at
that hotel I want to see John wick and
Dredd fight together so I
absolutely I want to see a that's that
was also when you brought up dread like
John wick was like a comic book yeah I
loved it yeah guys our next category's
best soundtrack slash score the music
that you put on you put the little iPod
buds in and your either working out
you're relaxing is taking you to another
place whatever you love to listen to and
to present we have gray Drake and Matt
actually guys what do you love to listen
to you in your downtime hey YouTube it's
great Drake from run Tomatoes and I am
here to present the award for best
soundtrack in score I had left my normal
habitat of Los Angeles for the one of
New York City I'm in Times Square
because Marvel just agreed that it would
produce the next spider-man movie and
I'm really excited about that I haven't
seen electro though thank God so I think
that I'll be able to get the good
citizens of this great city to help me
present our nominees and eventually our
winners so let's give it a shot by the
way guys I know the aspect ratio of this
video is off and not what you would find
on our Rotten Tomatoes YouTube channel
can you put a cute picture of a kitten
next to me oh wait
okay thanks all right the first nominee
is and gun do gun girl you got it
next up guardians of the galaxy whoa
interstellar yeah and finally and the
winner is guardians oh my god you guys
the Statue of Liberty really knows how
to party that was intense
there you go guardians win so guys back
to you in the studio and it's freezing
out here
so I can't wait to get back to Los
Angeles sorry New York but I love you
what can I say it was the hooked on the
feeling man it played in the trailer you
played that part in the trailer a
hundred times over and after that it
just takes them right there and I'll
tell you what I wasn't sure where he's
gonna go
I thought either it was gonna be
guardians because it has such a great
soundtrack for sure but then whiplash
was another one though yeah so well I
loved the Jazz I loved the jazz music I
thought whiplash would burn I'm not
gonna say what my vote was right you
know what in whiplash they take a couple
shots at rock drummers and how they're
not as good as jazz drummers technically
speaking well the rock drummers one out
because that cassette tape and guardians
of the galaxy one of the best
soundtracks I've ever heard you know why
I think also it was it one maybe is
because the soundtrack in guardians of
galaxy it really becomes like a
character it has so much personality
every song is played in the beginning
with the opening credits obviously from
the trailer music that that they used
it's so I understand why one I like the
fact that we're one of the only award
shows that does combine score on
soundtrack I know something a lot of
problem with it but I think that it's
you either it's either score or in the
past soundtrack someone in the past so I
like this change I think it also won
because it kicks ass it does doesn't it
does kick ass without it's 20 minutes
solo at the end of whiplash alright our
next category is best comedy because we
all love to laugh you love to laugh I
love to laugh you know that we all love
to laugh movie fans love to laugh and to
present best comedy we have AMC movie
talk with John Campea and
heroes
hey guys I'm John Campea and I'm Amy
Rose Eisenbach and we here at AMC movie
news are honored to present the you
reviewers awards category of Best Comedy
the nominees were as follows top five
neighbors 22 Jump Street the grand
budapest hotel and the interview and the
winner is 22 Jump Street which I'm
thrilled about because it happened to be
my favorite comedy the year but a great
list of comedies all in all right back
to you guys 22 Jump Street the movie
that was a sequel that knew it was a
sequel that made fun of the fact that it
was a sequel and that's why it won for
sure and talked about shock time he
didn't suck I'm shocked that it was
great yeah you shocked it was at least
as good as the first one yes and the
fact that they did playoff on it so much
is what made it so funny but I also
thought top five had a good shot that
was a movie came out of nowhere but 22
Jump Street from me was the funniest of
the year yeah there were some really
good comedies this year but 22 Jump
Street it does take the cake I mean it
was funny I love how it turned that
premise on its ear because like in the
first one where it kept making fun of
the fact that you're rebooting all these
TV shows this one made fun of the fact
that you always have unnecessary sequels
yet here especially the end credits if
you haven't seen the movie yet stayed
till the end because my god that end
credits scene might have won this award
for the money I think it absolutely did
it was one of those I mean I love a good
credit comedy but during the credits
yeah for sure it look good credit could
kind of County today so our next
category is Best Actress the women
leading the charge in movies to present
Best Actress we have the team from
screen junkies guys who is it
what's going on schmoeville I'm Hal
Rudnick from the screen junkies show and
I am so pumped to be part of the you
reviewers award we are giving out the
award for the category of Best Actress
and in honor of our new show movie
fights I'm going to read the nominees
and the voice of Macho Man Randy Savage
yeah the first nominee is
Rosamund Pike for gone girl coming up
next don't forget about the redhead
Julianne Moore for still Alice brother
who don't forget also about Felicity
Jones for the theory of everything and
last but not least brother is Davis for
the babadook I had a look her up name
cuz se Davis is not a household name and
the winner is Rosamund Pike for gone
girl whoo
don't forget to watch honest trailers to
screen junkies show movie fights and hit
me up on Twitter at Hal Rudnick thanks
for watching bye bye whoa I'll tell you
that that that's a whoa why do you
Rosamund Pike surprise mace because she
no no I'm not going to because you know
what this was the best sheet has ever
been and I don't want anybody to take
that away and it was it was really a
great performance but to beat out like
the heavy favorites here right Julie had
more we're still Alice right I mean
that's a big one that is huge the way
her character played out when I'm
actually watching gone girl going back
and forth as to whether I like the way
the storylines going but I never wavered
on my opinion of her performance in the
film she was amazing right not taking
anything away from her performance but
it might also be the fact that because
everyone's like it's like the shock it
didn't suck i socked Rosamund Pike's
knockin oh my god she was that good it's
this she's been a capable actress and
sometimes I didn't love her in that what
was the one judge a creature I didn't
love her then but you always saw the
potential though you're like I know it's
there didn't yes something are you sure
god I mean God girl man she switched so
many different levels she went
again if people that haven't seen the
movie see the movies here yeah
absolutely and if you haven't seen Die
Another Day note it and watch that
notice the fact that she apparently
doesn't age next category is Best
Director these are the guys behind the
camera these are the ones bringing you
everything you love to present Best
Director
I'm not gonna spoil it he's a handsome
guy and you know him he needs no
introduction take it away my god Jeremy
stop it man but you guys know me I don't
like long videos I'm gonna get right
into this the nominees for Best Director
are Alejandro Gonzales inner e24 Birdman
Richard Linklater for boyhood David
Fincher for gone girl
Damien Chazelle for whiplash and Ava
Duvernay for Selma and the winner is I
say winner is not award goes to because
I'm not PC and [ __ ] the winner is David
Fincher for gun girl Congrats
whoa who saw that coming is that you're
surprised interface that is my surprise
your Jean girl face that is just for
gone girl who suck I thought Interop 2
is gonna win this hands down or
Linklater and then Fincher comes out of
nowhere
I honestly be everywhere everyone loves
Fincher yeah I love Fincher I II thought
because David Fincher's well those guys
like all right you're gonna run out of
steam you're gonna make a movie that
maybe it doesn't flow too well and when
he when he made gun girl I was like yeah
he's still got it so it's not as much of
a surprise for me that he got gone where
you have your your your venture camp
those people are gonna be so loyal to ya
all right and then I think that Birdman
and boyhood people were going back and
forth and they were split so I think
David Fincher came right up you know
Main Street and ended up stealing an
award is too strong of a word because
gone girl took you on a riveting ride
too tough one though when you think of
what both you know a to and Link that's
a tough one because and that goes back
before that in other Awards he really
hasn't been talking about this one
people
I remember just when when you post a
review and we post a review about these
nominations or just about Oscar
she's people where's Spencer where's
Spencer where's lecture and there you
don't are you sure we can trust the guy
who's in the video for Best Director
announcing it I didn't like the look I
don't like maybe he maybe he C turn
there maybe was the different director
anyhow know this guy if there's anything
you should know about him dress is
better than you two always tell us the
truth Star Wars shut up [ __ ] all
right that is that is tough competition
alright guys so that is the end of part
1 of the you reviewers movie awards year
5 to half decade extravaganza so you're
asking yourself like where was Best
Picture Best Actor the coveted stink
pile of the Year award it's on these
guys Channel these are the schmoes know
that's where you can find part two
that's right and there was a lot of
great stuff that happened here again
very happy to be doing this with you
again for your 5 thank you to all the
your viewers that voted and make sure
because you want to see what you guys
pick go over our channel and check out
best pitcher and the rest of the awards
it's the sequel and sequels are always
as good as the original right 22 Jump
Street Caddyshack stop it Empire Strikes
Back said you know that's a trilogy you
can't count that
you